hier im Plenum geht es jetzt mit einem
sicherheitspolitischen Thema weiter und
zwar geht es um den Einsatz der
Bundeswehr in Mali in Westafrika
die Bundeswehr ist in zwei
Missionen aktiv einmal in der
stabilisierungsmission der Vereinten
Nationen kurz minusma und auch an der
eu-ausbildungsmission
eutm und es gibt zwei Anträge der
Oppositionen die sich nun fragt ob diese
Beteiligung der Bundeswehr notwendig und
vor allen Dingen effektiv ist die Union
befragt dass einerseits und möchte eine
Überprüfung dieser Bundeswehr Einsätze
denn sie sagt seit neun Jahren sehr man
keine Verbesserungen seit neun Jahren
Einsatz und die afd-fraktion fordert in
ihrem Antrag gleich die Bundeswehr
Einsätze in Mali und Niger zu beenden
erster Redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion ist Jürgen hart wir
Außenpolitiker der Union hatten gestern
die Chance mit dem Chef von minusma mit
Herrn Bahne zu sprechen über den Einsatz
wir haben in diesem Gespräch verspürt
die große Sorge von den warne das wenn
sich weitere Nationen nun nach
Frankreich abmelden würden aus diesem
Einsatz die Situation in Mali
zusehends und handelbar wird und dass
wir deshalb dringend dazu aufgefordert
werden sind unseren Beitrag weiter zu
leisten er hat auch von den
Schwierigkeiten berichtet die er hat
bestimmte
unterstützungskernelemente der
Unterstützung zu bekommen wir wissen das
auch dass wir nicht zufrieden sein
können mit der Frage Helikopter
Unterstützung luftnahe Unterstützung in
diesem Einsatz das wird im Augenblick
von El Salvador und dann schon im Wald
von Bangladesch geleistet die sicherlich
als Soldaten hoch engagiert sind die
aber mit dem Gerät was ihnen dafür zur
Verfügung steht nicht an das
heranreichen was eigentlich unser
Maßstab ist
wir haben diesen Antrag hier im
Deutschen Bundestag gestellt weil wir
wissen dass es bei allen Fraktionen auch
bei denen die diesen Einsatz
unterstützen große Bauchschmerzen gibt
mit der gegenwärtigen Situation dieses
Einsatzes und zur Soldaten sind
angesichts der gegenwärtigen Lage ich
hatte das Thema Luft nachunterstützung
angesprochen gezwungen letztlich viel
Arbeit im Camp zu vollbringen statt
tatsächlich effektiv
bei den Menschen in Mali zu wirken wir
haben
Schwierigkeiten mit der malischen
Regierung Frau agnesstag Zimmermann die
fdp-ausschussvorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses hat im Sommer
kritisiert das würde das
Verteidigungsministerium mit einer
anderen Stimme als das Außenministerium
mit der Regierung im Bamako reden wir
beobachten dass die Regierung in Bamako
Unterstützung von russischen
Söldnertruppen bekommt Truppen vor denen
wir wissen dass sie vor
völkerrechtsfrüchten und vor dem Bruch
von unter Achtung von Menschenrechten
nicht zurückschrecken das können keine
Partner von minusma keine Partner der
deutschen Bundeswehr in der Region sein
bei diesen ganz vielen
offenen Fragen hat uns die
Bundesregierung im Mai einen Antrag zur
Fortsetzung dass man Dates vorgelegt der
letztlich nicht wesentlich keine
wesentlichen Veränderungen vorgesehen
hat und sie hat angekündigt dass für den
Fall dass bestimmte Parameter nicht
eingehalten werden der Einsatz überprüft
werden muss
wir stellen fest dass einzelne Parameter
dieses Einsatzes nicht eingehalten
werden können Beispiel das Thema
luftnahe Unterstützung aber dennoch
vermissen und trotzdem gibt es seitens
der Bundesregierung keinen neuen Ansatz
keine Weiterentwicklung des Konzeptes in
Sachen Mali unser Antrag soll dazu
beitragen und ich möchte es wirklich als
auch eine als Einladung an die anderen
Fraktionen verstehen dass wir in den
nächsten Wochen doch tatsächlich diesen
Einsatz in der Form evaluieren dass wir
uns überlegen kann er so weitergehen ich
glaube nein und wenn er weitergeht was
auch unser Ziel sein muss in welcher
Form muss er weitergeführt werden ganz
konkret zum Beispiel stelle ich die
Frage an die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
wenn wir solche Schwierigkeiten haben
die notwendige Luft nachunterstützung zu
bekommen und auf Nationen wie El
Salvador und Bangladesch angewiesen sind
warum können wir dies nicht tatsächlich
doch selbst leisten mit unseren Tiger
Kampfhubschraubern und unseren Nr 90
Transporthubschraubern das will mir
nicht in den Kopf warum wir diesen
Schritt nicht in der Lage sind zu gehen
das wäre ein kraftvolles Zeichen auch
gegenüber den Vereinten Nationen die
Situation
die Situation in Mali ist ausgesprochen
fragil wir wissen aber dass wenn es zu
einem totalen kollapsdirektion käme wir
nicht nur massive humanitäre negative
Auswirkungen auf die Bevölkerung die
Menschen in der Region hätten und auf
die Entwicklung dieser Regionen
insgesamt sondern natürlich auch die
Terrorgefahr wieder steigen würde
weltweit natürlich der Terror sich auch
gegen Industrienationen nicht richtet
und das nicht zuletzt viele Menschen
gezwungen sein könnten ihr Land zu
verlassen was wir auch nicht wollen in
diesem Sinne machen sie machen Sie mit
uns eine gute Beratung dieses Antrags
und hinterher eine breite Mehrheit dafür
dankeschön
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich grüße
Sie alle herzlich an diesem
Freitagnachmittag sehe sie in aller
Frische und wir fahren fort in der
Debatte mit dr karambagiabi für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die
Weltgemeinschaft schaut derzeit auf die
Klimakonferenz in Ägypten die Folgen der
Klimakrise treffen besonders den
globalen Süden im Frühjahr habe ich
mir bei einer Reise in Mali und Niger
mir wirklich selbst ein Bild der
dramatische Lage machen können es ist
unsere Pflicht dort Verantwortung zu
tragen wurde humanitäre Versorgungslage
besonders schlecht ist die seilregion
ist nicht nur durch die Klimakrise
geschwächt die Menschen dort und
speziell in Mali sind auch durch eine
fragile Sicherheitslage gefährdet
deswegen begrüße ich dass wir heute
erneut über unsere Engagement in Mali
sprechen aber in ihrem Antrag Liebe
Union beziehen sie sich wieder einmal
stark auf die Themen Migration und
Sicherheit und argumentieren damit an
den wirklichen Ursachen der
Herausforderungen vorbei
sie fordern eine Evaluation nach der
anderen ich sage wir können uns auch
über evaluieren
stattdessen sollten wir unseren Blick in
die Zukunft richten und nach
adäquatenlösungen und Alternativen
suchen daher begrüße ich den Vorstoß des
UN-Generalsekretärs
wir nutzen wir durch einen
nachfolgemission der Afrikanischen Union
zu ersetzen darüber lieber cdu/csu
diskutieren wir in meiner Fraktion
übrigens schon seit September seit Ende
September festgeht eine au-mission
könnte zentrale Baustein dafür sein dass
die jetzige Mission in Mali schrittweise
ausläuft was bedeutet das 1 die
nachfolgermission braucht finanzielle
logistische und materielle Unterstützung
der internationalen Partner
zweitens eine politische transition und
die Umsetzung des Friedensabkommen
müssen weiterhin Ziel bleiben drittens
ein Übergang muss Schritt für Schritt
und eng mit menisma sowie mit Mali
abgestimmt werden aber die au-mission in
Mali wird nicht von heute auf morgen
realisierbar sein deswegen ist es
wichtig denn ein Satz der Bundeswehr
nicht über eil zu beenden oder nach
Niger zu verlegen wie einige das zuvor
schlagen meine sehr verehrten
nein Afrika ist kein Problem Kontinent
mehr den wir finanziell unterstützen
müssen damit wir
Migrationsströme abwehren
das afrikanische Selbstbewusstsein
stecken längst nicht mehr in den
Kinderschuhen
es hat sich emanzipiert ich nehme dafür
drei authentische Stimmen
erstens der Präsident der Afrikanische
Union makisal macht er auf dem Forum für
Frieden und Sicherheit in der Karten
deutlich dass Afrika nicht mehr auf
externe Akteure Seelen können
stattdessen müssen Lösungen von innen
heraus entwickelt werden zweite Stimmung
Herr Musa der Kommissar von Frieden und
Sicherheit der ecovaz fragte
warum immer im Außen nach Lösungen zu
suchen Fragezeichen und dritter Meinung
fasst Frau danahl von stimmenzentren
Lösungen müssen von lokalen Akteuren
definiert werden sie müssen auch von
lokalen Akteure umgesetzt werden
internationale Akteure sollten
unterstützen aber die Führung muss auch
aus Afrika kommen ich sage das neue
afrikanische Selbstbewusstsein müssen
wir respektieren wenn wir ein
langfristiger langfristiger Partner sein
wollen mit Blick auf das internationale
Geschehen wird klar
mali ist nicht isoliert Mali hat erkannt
dass ein sein ein Alleingang mit
Russland nicht zielführend ist dass wir
merken wir auch bei einigen
Veröffentlichungen mali ist auch mit
Frankreich und den regionaler
Organisationen im Austausch meine sehr
verehrten
eine Werte geleitet Außenpolitik
bedeutet für mich nicht Abzug sondern
Engagement und Verantwortung Engagement
und verantwortung heißt auch für mich
dass wir den transitionsprozess in Mali
aktiv unterstützen erst gestern habe ich
auch mit Herrn one er hat sie haben
darüber gesprochen wir haben auch mit
ihm gesprochen Herr One ist Leiter von
minusma und über den Einsatz in Mali
haben wir gestern gesprochen er betonte
dass bis 2024 geplante Neuwahlen
gefährdet sind wenn wir uns jetzt
militärisch zurückziehen Ziel unserer
ist dass es den Menschen vor Ort besser
geht das bleibt auch weiterhin dringend
notwendig denn
20.000 Schulen müssen ja müssten
schließen in Mali und 1,2 Millionen
Menschen sind von der Hunger dort
bedroht es ist entscheidend also dass
wir unsere internationalen Verantwortung
sowohl auf der
Weltklimakonferenz als auch bei der
multilateralen Friedensmission
Nachkommen deshalb lassen sie uns
Gespräch bleiben weil wir denken es ist
wichtig ist dass wir Entscheidungen
treffen wo wir Menschen in Mali mit
einbeziehen das wird afrikanische
Organisation mit einbeziehen dankeschön
ist auch Vorsitzender der Parlamentarier
Gruppe
Westafrika und hat sich hier zu den
Anträgen von Union und AFD geäußert für
die afd-fraktion spricht nun Joachim von
drag
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der Deutsche Bundestag befasst sich
heute wohl zum sechsten Mal in diesem
Jahr mit dem Bundeswehr einsetzen in
Mali und dem Sahel diesmal auf Antrag
der Union ich darf daran erinnern dass
wir die afd-fraktion diese Einsätze in
jeder dieser Debatten in diesem Hause
als gescheitert bezeichnet haben und
dringend den Abzug der deutschen
Soldaten aus Mali gefordert haben
die Union stellt nun in ihrem Antrag
ebenfalls fest dass die Einsätze minusma
und eutm völlig gescheitert sind danach
mehr als neun Jahren die
sicherheitspolitische Gesamtlage nicht
nur nicht sich nicht verbessert hat
sondern einen regionalpolitischer
Scherbenhaufen festzustellen ist weiter
wird festgestellt dass alle anderen
westlichen Akteure ihre Truppen bereits
abgezogen haben oder den Abzug planen
Präsident macron hat erst vor zwei Tagen
das offizielle Ende der Operation bacane
verkündet die dadurch entstandenen
fähigkeitsverluste haben die
Gefährdungslage in einem Maß erhöht dass
die Bundeswehr ihren Auftrag in Mali
nicht erfüllen kann
statt aber der nach der zutreffenden
Analyse dieses Desasters die einzig
logische Konsequenz zu ziehen nämlich
diese fortige Beendigung der Einsätze
und den Abzug der deutschen Soldaten zu
fordern er geht sich der Antrag der
Union in Forderungen nach Entwicklung
von neuen Strategien und zusätzlichen
evaluation
die Union muss sich an dieser Stelle die
Frage gefallen lassen welche umfassende
Strategie für Mali und den Sahel hat sie
denn in all den Jahren entwickelt in
denen sie für die Einsätze
verantwortlich war statt den Abzug zu
fordern wird im Antrag unterstellt dass
wohl das Engagement der internationalen
Gemeinschaft in Mali nicht groß genug
gewesen sein
und so wird die Bundesregierung in
diesem Antrag der Union aufgefordert
Fähigkeitslücken zu identifizieren und
für das Schließen dieser
Fähigkeitslücken zu sorgen
dies würde in der Konsequenz und wir
haben das eben auch schon gehört die
weitere und signifikante Erhöhung der
deutschen des deutschen militärischen
Beitrags in Mali bedeuten da wie gesagt
alle anderen westlichen Akteure die
richtige Konsequenz gezogen haben
nämlich den Abzug wir kennen dieses
Phänomen der schleichenden
auftragserweiterungen des Mission creep
aus anderen Einsätzen zu genüge und wir
sollten dem Beispiel der Franzosen
folgen die auch in afghanistagen
rechtzeitig vor der Katastrophe
ausgestiegen sind
und schließlich wird dann der Antrag der
Union richtig abenteuerlich so
Schließung der militärischen
fähigkeitslücke luftnahunterstützung
wird die Bundesregierung aufgefordert
unverzüglich am Markt verfügbare
Hubschrauber zu beschaffen
für eine Fraktion die in den letzten 30
Jahren überwiegend Verantwortung für die
Bundeswehr und damit auch für die
Rüstung getragen hat eine wirklich
erstaunlich unrealistische Forderung wie
lange sollen die Soldaten in Mali denn
auf die zu beschaffende
Luftunterstützung warten dies wäre nach
meiner Erfahrung eher in Jahren als in
Monaten zu beziffern aus meiner Sicht
ein absoluter Unsinn wir lehnen den
Antrag der Union daher ab obwohl wir der
Analyse der Situation in Mali weitgehend
zustimmen können denn mit den
vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen der Ausweitung
des Einsatzes werden sie den Einsatz in
Mali weder politisch noch militärisch
zum Einsatz führen zum Erfolg führen
können sie werden scheitern und noch
mehr Schaden anrichten materiell und an
Leib und Leben unserer Soldaten
wir empfehlen dagegen unseren Antrag
zuzustimmen und die Bundeswehreinsätze
in der saalzone schleunigst zu beenden
ich wiederhole hier meine Forderung an
die Bundesregierung vom Frühjahr dieses
Jahres wollen sie die Gruppe aus der
Sahel zurück bevor wir das Scheitern
dieser Mission aus der mit Milliarden
von Euros auch mit Leib und Leben
unserer Soldaten bezahlen müssen wir
haben wichtiges zu tun nämlich
konzentrationschluss auf Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung das ist der
verfassungsgemäße Auftrag der Bundeswehr
Deutschland wird eben nicht im Saal
verteidigt ich verdanke für die
Aufmerksamkeit ich danke Joachim
wunderrad aus der afd-fraktion hat hier
interessanterweise fast nur den Antrag
der Unionsfraktion beschlossen ist
nämlich der einzige Redner der
afd-fraktion und so blieben für diesen
Antrag nur noch ein paar Sätze übrig
Merle Spellerberg jetzt für Bündnis 90
die Grünen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen viele
von uns wir haben ja am Dienstag wie
jedes Jahr vor Weihnachten auf den
gelben Bändern des Bundeswehrverbandes
wieder unsere Verbundenheit mit den
Soldatinnen im Auslandseinsatz
niedergeschrieben diese Bänder sind
jetzt wieder auf den Weg unter anderem
in den Norden Marlies in das Camp Castor
im Gau
ich bin im Bundeswehrverband sehr
dankbar dass wir so auch abseits dieser
reden im Plenum und unseren Gesprächen
mit der Truppe vor Ort die Gelegenheit
haben diese Verbundenheit und unseren
höchsten Respekt vor dem Einsatz auch so
zum Ausdruck bringen zu können
denn gerade auch Mali das wissen wir
hier alle ist die gefährlichste Mission
in der die Bundeswehr derzeit aktiv ist
das dürfen wir niemals vergessen und
deswegen würde ich eigentlich auch gerne
sagen dass ich froh bin an dieser Stelle
wieder darüber sprechen zu können ich
hatte allerdings tatsächlich ein
bisschen Schwierigkeiten den Zeitpunkt
nachzuvollziehen der Kollege Karamba
diabi ist darauf schon eingegangen die
UN-Mission wird evaluiert sinnvoll wäre
es dann noch einmal dazu zu sprechen
die Militärregierung ist für uns ein
mindestens unbequemer Partner in der
Zusammenarbeit das ist kein Geheimnis
haben wir in den letzten Monaten immer
wieder mit Problemen und Behinderung
umgehen müssen
mangelnde Überfluggenehmigung
Verhinderung von Rotation
das lag in Teilen aber eben auch an der
Umstellung der Verfahren auf UN-Ebene
und daraus resultierenden Verzögerungen
und nicht ausschließlich am mangelnden
Goodwill der transitionsregierung
das Magie etwa die Hoheit über seinen
eigenen Luftraum haben will ist erstmal
nachzuvollziehen gerade auch mit Blick
auf die koloniale Vergangenheit doch was
nicht im Sinne der malischen Regierung
sein kann ist die Arbeit der Mission so
zu erschweren wie es eben in Teilen
passiert ist deswegen ist es unfassbar
wichtig dass wir Schritt für Schritt
wieder daran arbeiten die Zusammenarbeit
zu verbessern
wir brauchen eben abseits dessen eine
bessere Aufstellung des Mandates wir
brauchen auch selber eine bessere
Aufstellung im Minus Hauptquartier und
auch das wurde schon angesprochen die
Zusammenarbeit mit der Afrikanischen
Union
und es ist unfassbar wichtig und gut das
auf un Ebene minusma evaluiert wird und
wenn das passiert ist müssen auch wir
daraus unsere Schlüsse ziehen und daran
anpassen die UN braucht es als
Stabilitätsanker in den in der Regionen
denn wer wenn nicht die Afrikanische
Union und die vereinte Nation kann diese
Rolle hier verantwortungsbewusst
übernehmen Russland wohl kaum
eine verhältst Strategie wie sie es
fordern braucht es definitiv da gibt es
ja gar keine gar keine Differenzen
unsererseits und deswegen arbeitet das
Auswärtige Amt ja kontinuierlich auch
daran
und das 2015 verabschiedete
Friedensabkommen von Algier hat ja
durchaus einige Erfolge vorzuweisen und
Sicherheit und Stabilität in Teilen
hervorgebracht
trotzdem bleibt die Gesamtlage
herausfordernd
Anschläge durch Terrorgruppen gerade im
Norden Marlies sind leider Alltag und zu
oft müssen Menschenleben beklagt werden
die wirtschaftlichen Probleme sind
tiefgehend und die staatlichen
Strukturen höchst instabil aber gerade
eben in Gau gibt es bekanntermaßen
weniger Anschläge dort herrscht mehr
Sicherheit und dazu tragen unsere
Truppen bei durch ihre Präsenz
und was wir auch am Anfang unserer am
Anfang des Jahres bei der Reise mit der
Außenministerin immer wieder gehört
haben Vertrauen in den Staat kommt eben
nicht einfach nur durch Wahlen ja Wahlen
sind wichtig aber wenn deine Sicherheit
geschweige denn deine Freiheit das Recht
auf Entfaltung nicht gewährleistet ist
dann liegen die Prioritäten häufig
erstmal anders und was sowohl
Soldatinnen als auch die Menschen vor
Ort immer wieder gesagt haben ist im
Norden ist Bamako erstmal ziemlich weit
weg
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
dort sind dass wir unterstützen und im
Stabilität im Saal zu erreichen braucht
es eben die Gewährleistung von
Sicherheit auf ganz vielen verschiedenen
Ebenen die Gewährleistung von
menschlicher Sicherheit und dazu trägt
minusma als Gesamtansatz der UN bei und
Deutschland trägt zum minusma bei die
Debatte über die Weiterführung und
Strategie ist eine die wir im globalen
Kontext führen müssen das betrifft
sowohl die Ausstattung als auch die
Ausrichtung für eine dauerhafte
Stabilität in der verhelzone zusammen
mit den beitragenden Staaten in den
Vereinten Nationen wenn wir jetzt
überstürzt die Zelte abbrechen und
unsere Partner ihnen zurücklassen dann
verlieren wir zum einen das Ansehen
unserer internationalen partner:innen
zum anderen das Vertrauen der Menschen
in Mali und vor allem hinterlassen wir
zusätzlich ein Vakuum das Russland nur
zu gerne füllen würde und auch das kann
nicht im Interesse unserer
Sicherheitspolitik sein
und ich würde an dieser Stelle wirklich
in meiner verbleibenden Zeit gerne noch
auf konkrete Vorschläge und Ideen von
ihrem Antrag eingehen aber sind einfach
auch nicht so viele zu finden
ja haben wir gelesen
und falls sie eben doch noch Ideen haben
dann würde ich mich tatsächlich freuen
diese gemeinsamen Ausschuss zu
diskutieren weil zum Beispiel die
russischen disson Informationskampagnen
die Sie angesprochen haben sind ein
Problem wenn sie da also doch noch Ideen
haben dann freue ich mich darüber in den
Austausch zu kommen am Ende steht für
uns fest dass man dort minusma ist für
uns kein Selbstzweck und darf es niemals
sein wir unterstützen Mali wertegeleitet
für Sicherheit für Stabilität den Schutz
von Menschenrechten und Menschenleben
wir unterstützen die Menschen in Mali
danke
Merle Spellerberg hat hier angekündigt
gerne an den Austausch zu kommen und das
ist auch möglich denn diese beiden
Anträge werden nach dieser Debatte noch
in die entsprechenden Ausschüsse
überwiesen und dort weiter diskutiert
andere Hugo der europapolitische
Sprecher der Linksfraktion ist nun am
Rednerpult vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
ich habe ein bisschen an DejaVu hier 20
Jahre lang haben wir hier
uns immer wieder den Afghanistan Einsatz
schön geredet mittlerweile gibt es eine
encat-kommission die diesen Einsatz
aufarbeitet und was dabei herauskommt
ist zum Beispiel das einfach eine
ehrliche
Evaluierung und auch eine Konsequenz aus
dieser ehrlichen Evaluierung über die 20
Jahre gefehlt hat etwas ähnliches möchte
ich jetzt beim Einsatz in Mali nicht
erleben
wir diskutieren heute
einen Antrag außerhalb der üblichen
Mandatsverlängerung einen Antrag der
cdu/csu der in seiner Analyse völlig
eindeutig ist ich zitiere
trotz inzwischen Neunjähriger minus war
Mission und intensive Unterstützung
Marlies im Rahmen der European Training
Mission OTM Mali sind keine
Verbesserungen erkennbar
regionalpolitisch zeigt sich ein
Scherbenhaufen sowohl was die Situation
in einzelnen Staaten anbelangt als auch
in der Beziehung war Markus zur Region
und so weiter und so fort der die ganze
Analyse Teil ist eigentlich eine
Abrechnung mit dem Einsatz den sie
selbst über viele Jahre hier
vorangetrieben haben
die Frage und eigentlich wäre die
Konsequenz dann tatsächlich das was die
meisten westlichen Akteure mittlerweile
gemacht haben vor allen Dingen auch die
Franzosen sich aus diesem Einsatz
zurückzuziehen aber sie fordern
sie fordern hier
weitere mit Beschaffung von
Hubschraubern um sozusagen noch mehr
diesen Einsatz militärisch auszustarten
ich halte das für falsch die Reden die
hier auch Frau spellenberg und Herr
dyabi diese gehalten haben erinnere mich
auch sehr an die Afghanistan Debatte es
wurde immer schön geredet es wurde
gesagt werden wir jetzt abziehen dann
wird es noch schlimmer am Ende weil das
Fiasko viel größer auch wenn es einige
Aspekte gibt die ich da
ranteile ich teile die Kritik am
cdu/csu-ansatz Mali und die Sahelzone
ausschließlich unter
sicherheitspolitischen Aspekten zu sehen
ich teile die Kritik anders immer noch
bestehenden
kolonialen Attitüde mit der gegenüber
diesen Staaten umgegangen wird ich habe
das hier schon mal gesagt die Staaten in
der Region
emanzipieren sich zunehmend und bestehen
auf ihrer Souveränität und insofern
teile ich auch den Ansatz von Mackie
sell aus aus dem Senegal dass die
Lösungen von innen kommen müssen wenn
ich das alles zusammenfasse wir haben
über 4 Milliarden Euro in diesem
mali-einsatz investiert wenn man sich
vorstellt das solche Ansätze zivil
genutzt worden wären glaube ich werden
wir sehr viel weiter ich denke es ist
gut dass wir diskutieren über Mali aber
ich denke dieser ein Militäreinsatz in
Mali sollte er früher als später beendet
werden vielen Dank
für die FDP-Fraktion erhält das Wort
Alexander Graf Lambsdorff
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Antrag eines nicht ist dann ist es
eindeutig
aber er hält enthält einen Kernsatz der
ist glaube ich der Ausgangspunkt der
Debatte er sollte jedenfalls der
Ausgangspunkt der Debatte sein und ich
stimme diesem Kernsatz vollumfänglich
zunehmend heißt wie folgt die Stabilität
der sahelregion liegt im
Sicherheitsinteresse Deutschlands und
Europas die Folgen wachsender
Instabilität und zunehmender Migration
werden in Europa unmittelbar zu spüren
sein das stimmt das ist so aber was
folgt daraus daraus folgt dass wir ein
Engagement in der Region brauchen und
zwar ein Engagement im vernetzten Ansatz
das politische entwicklungspolitische
und militärische sicherheitspolitische
Komponenten zusammen denkt das ist die
Konsequenz aus diesem kernsatzes
unionsantrages so und dann kommen wir zu
einer Instrumenten Diskussion die kann
man für
und das eine Instrument das wir haben
interessanterweise nimmt den Gedanken
des vernetzten Ansatzes schon im Namen
auf dass i in minusma heißt erntegriert
die integrierte vernetzte Mission der
Vereinten Nationen in Mali fangen wir
mit der Politik an die politische
Unterstützung der Vereinten Nationen
sowohl für die Gewährleistung von
grunddienstleistungen an die Bevölkerung
ist unentbehrlich bei Malko alleine kann
es zurzeit ohne die Vereinten Nationen
nicht leisten es gibt einen
übergangsplan zur Demokratie mit einem
wahlkalender im Verfassungsreferendum im
März Kommunalwahlen im Juni
Parlamentswahlen im November und im
Februar 24 die Präsidentschaftswahlen
all das unter Ägide der Vereinten
Nationen das ist der demokratische der
politische Fahrplan militärisch das
problematisierte Antrag zurecht und wir
diskutieren es in der Koalition ja
genauso klar es gibt Probleme und man
darf sie auch nicht wecken oder
kleinreden
mit der Rotation mit medifeck
luftnahunterstützung mit der Bürokratie
mit den Drohnen und ich war jetzt gerade
eine Woche über eine Woche in diesen
drei Ländern unterwegs Mali Burkina
Phase und Niger ich habe dem
Außenminister von Mali das sehr klar
gesagt und das ist auch sehr hart
gemacht diesen Punkt dass das für uns
bei der Entscheidung darüber ob unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten bleiben können
sich verbessern muss er hat das auch
konstruktiv aufgenommen und ich hoffe
dass daraus sich was entwickelt genauso
wie der der spezielle Vertreter des
Generalsekretärs mit dem wir uns hier
vor einigen Tagen auch in Berlin
getroffen haben
was sie allerdings im Antrag über die
Präsenz im Feld schreiben Liebe Union
das ist schlicht falsch sie schreiben es
gäbe keine Präsenz der Bundeswehr im
Feld wegen der Probleme die sie an der
ein oder anderen Stelle am stimmt
einfach nicht die swee speak während wir
hier stehen ist die aufklärungskompanie
in ansongo im Einsatz in einer
vierwöchigen Mission zur Sicherung der
Straße von Mali nach Niger die sind
draußen im Feld in einem vierwöchigen
Einsatz außerhalb des Lagers also es ist
nicht ganz so schlecht wie sie es hier
teilweise anklingen lassen und der
dritte Punkt im militärischen Kontext
den sie schreiben ist ja ist ein
russische Sölden Einbau ich war selbst
in Gau ich habe es gesehen ich bin am
Eingang des Camps dort vorbeigefahren
aber jetzt mal im ernst
ein paar russische Söldner können doch
nicht ausschlaggebend dafür sein ob wir
über 1.100 1.200 Bundeswehrsoldaten
jetzt so oder so entscheiden
Entschuldigung wir bewundern die
ukrainische Armee für den Widerstand
ihren Kampf gegen die russischen
Streitkräfte kommen drei Dutzend Söldner
und wir ziehen unsere Leute zurück
deswegen nein im Gegenteil das russische
Engagement in Afrika ist ja Teil eines
großen einkreisungsplans gegenüber
Westeuropa gehen Sie doch mal Belarus
Serbien Syrien Libyen Algerien
Zentralafrikanische Republik jetzt auch
Mali russland hat eine Politik verfolgt
eine Politik zur Kontrolle der
Migrationsrouten erinnern wir uns bitte
an die Bilder von der
belarussisch-polnischen Grenze das war
ein ganz kleiner Vorgeschmack auf das
was passiert wenn wir den Russen die
Kontrolle in Saal Überlassen von daher
glaube ich das kann keine Antwort sein
es kann kein Kriterium sein wegen ein
paar söldenern die sich in so ein großes
Konzept einfügen den Rückzug jetzt
anzutreten das darf nicht passieren
sie verlangen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union der Evaluierung da kann ich Sie
beruhigen die läuft
innerhalb der Bundesregierung wird sie
im Dezember kommen innerhalb von minus
mal selber wird man der Evaluierung
machen die wird im Januar den
Sicherheitsrat vorgelegt wir werden
beides hier im Deutschen Bundestag
debattieren und daraus auch unsere
Schlüssel ziehen das Fazit meine Damen
und Herren
wir brauchen eine instrumentendiskussion
wie sind wir wo erfolgreich wir brauchen
ein regionales Engagement in die Lage in
Mali ist schwierig aber in Burkina Faso
haben wir eine beratermission der
Bundeswehr wir haben in Niger zurzeit
Gazelle wo wir uns jetzt zurückziehen wo
unser Footprint erheblich kleiner wird
wir brauchen den vernetzten Ansatz wir
müssen Sicherheit Entwicklung und
Politik weiterhin zusammen denken und
und das ist ein Punkt wo ich dem
unionsantrag zustimme wir brauchen eine
strategische Orientierung und deswegen
würde auch ich mir eine Sahel Strategie
aus dem Auswärtigen Amt wünschen die wir
hier im Deutschen Bundestag debattieren
und mit der wir die öffentliche Debatte
führen können herzlichen Dank
soweit der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP Alexander
Graf Lamsdorf und er hat es angesprochen
die Koalitionsfraktionen hatten sich
auch schon in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
darauf geeinigt die Einsätze der
Bundeswehr zu evaluieren Armin Schwarz
spricht nun für die Unionsfraktion und
Kollegen wir haben diesen Antrag
einbringen müssen weil die
Bundesregierung keine Entscheidung
trifft keine Entscheidung darüber trifft
wie es mit unserem militärischen Einsatz
in Mali weitergeht
sein Zaudern ein Zögern ein wahres
andeuten aus der Regierung Sören aber es
gibt keine klare Aussage
man hört aus dem Grün geführten
Außenministerium man möchte unsere
Soldaten und Soldaten in Mali belassen
da gibt es gute Gründe für Kollege Graf
hatte eben gerade darauf hingewiesen da
gibt es sehr gute Gründe für aus dem Rot
geführten
Verteidigungsministerium hört man
Tendenzen man würde lieber unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten ausholen der
Bundeskanzler schweigt mal wieder
und ich sage sehr deutlich in dieser
Situation ist es geboten eine klare
Aussage zu treffen denn man braucht eine
Entscheidung und ich will sehr deutlich
darauf hinweisen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es wurde uns zugesagt dass im
Herbst diesen Jahres eine Entscheidung
seit der Bundesregierung darüber
getroffen werden soll wie es mit unserem
Mali Engagement weitergeht und ich halte
das auch für richtig dass das so gesagt
wurde nur wir haben mittlerweile im
November eine Aussage und eine Tendenz
ist nicht erkennbar ich begrüße es dass
wir jetzt hören dass eine
Strategie für die seilzone vorgelegt
werden soll da fordern wir ja auch
ausdrücklich zur auf aber es wird dann
auch Zeit meine Damen und Herren sofern
bitte ich Sie sehr geben Sie
diesbezüglich Gas im Interesse und unser
Soldaten
denn liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen die
Leidtragenden sind in der Tat unsere
Soldate und Soldaten und auch hohe
Militärs sagen hinter vorgehaltener Hand
einen gefährlichen Auslandseinsatz
braucht man Klarheit auch Herr Kollege
ich teile des Einschätzung ausdrücklich
man muss zeigen welche Instrumente man
hat du musst klar sagen welche
Kooperationen haben mit welchen Partnern
innerhalb von minusma man agiert bin da
ausdrücklich ihrer Auffassung nur das
muss dann auch geschehen und deswegen
gestatten Sie mir einen Blick auf die
aktuelle Lage vor Ort ich stelle fest
nach langem Hin und Her ist jetzt für
November wieder die Möglichkeit gegeben
mit
überflugrechten für personalratation zu
sorgen und auch Versorgungsflüge zu
starten ich sage Gott sei Dank
dann sage ich aber auch sehr klar was
ist meteron 1 unsere Aufklärungsdrohne
die bleibt am Boden weswegen ist das so
weil offensichtlich Moskau nicht möchte
dass wir mit unseren Hero und eins
Drohnen wissen was die wagnergruppen
dort machen man muss das in dieser
Deutlichkeit artikulieren das bedeutet
wir sind ohne Bild
zusammenfassen ihre Redezeit ist schon
überschritten
ich komme ich komme zum letzten Satz
noch so viel zu sagen frau Präsidentin
selbstverständlich ich fasse ich fasse
zusammen seine ernste Situation wir
müssen eine konzertierte Aktion fahren
und vor allen Dingen müssen wir Klarheit
schaffen wir unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten das sind wir ihnen schuldig und
der allerletzt müssen sie wirklich zum
Schluss kommen unsere Interessen werden
natürlich mit allen Risiken auch in der
saalezone vertreten und insofern bitte
ich sehr liebe Bundesregierung kommen
Sie in die Wertung die Soldaten und
Soldaten und die Region wird Ihnen dafür
danken bedanke mich für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Armin Schwarz war das hier für die
Unionsfraktion
Christoph Schmidt spricht nun für die
SPD er sitzt im Verteidigungsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wie sie
es vermutlich schon geahnt haben oder
wissen ich bestätige sie nie gerne ich
komme aus Bayern und wenn es eine
Konstante in der bayerischen
Landespolitik gibt dann die Tatsache
dass dort im Landtag gute und sinnvolle
Nacht dazu vernünftig ausgearbeitete
Anträge der Oppositionsparteien zunächst
von der CSU niedergestimmt werden und
dann ein halbes Jahr später als eigene
Anträge und Ideen verkauft werden dann
ist das tatsächlich die einzige
Konstante die es da gibt dreimal dürfen
Sie raten worauf ich heute gehofft hatte
also sie ist von der Union kommt ein
Antrag zu Salz ohne
zwar arbeiten wir schon lange an
Lösungen für die Situation in der
saalzone habe ich gebe zu ich hatte eine
gewisse Hoffnung eine kleine Hoffnung
dass in ihrem Antrag der ein oder andere
Aspekt enthalten sein könnte oder
Ausgabe würde den man in die
Überlegungen mit einfließen lassen
könnte
so kann man sich täuschen das war sie
uns davor gesetzt haben ist inhaltlich
entweder nicht relevant oder neu und
sprachlich ist es zumindest in Teilen
fragwürdig
den Einsatz militärisch zum Erfolg
führen zu wollen klingt für mich und für
viele andere dann doch zu sehr nach
billigem säbelrassen wenn der Erfolg den
man sich dann erwartet überhaupt nicht
klar und präzise definiert wird und das
haben sie ganz einfach nicht gemacht
also mache ich es für sie was bedeutet
für sie politische Erfolg und was auch
hoffen Sie sich von militärischem Erfolg
weil sie es eben nicht ausbuchstabiert
haben kann ich es nur zwischen den
Zeilen des Antrags herauslesen ich will
es an zwei Beispielen greifbar machen
sie schreiben dass für eine Wirkung in
der Breite des Landes ich zitiere das
Engagement der internationalen
Gemeinschaft nicht groß genug war zum
anderen die innenpolitische Stabilität
Marlies sowie die
Mitwirkungsbereitschaft der malischen
Regierung nicht groß genug waren
wäre jetzt also die Änderung dieses
Zustands der von ihnen erhoffte
politische Erfolg zumute es zumindest
vermute ich das warum sagen Sie das dann
aber auch nicht und vor allem sagen sie
uns nicht wie Sie das erreichen wollen
beim militärischen Erfolg den sie ringen
wollen da würde ich folgen den Satz als
Messlatte für die von ihnen erhofften
Verbesserungen nehmen ich zitiere de
facto gibt es nun keine robuste Mission
unter westlicher Führung die einen
Verfolgungsdruck gegenüber den
terroristischen Gruppen aufrechterhält
Zitat Ende mal unabhängig davon dass man
hier reininterpretieren kann dass sie
von der Bundeswehr eine aktive Rolle bei
der Terrorbekämpfung in Mali erwarten
würden hätte ich in eine möglicherweise
ein wenig naiven Politikverständnis
jetzt erwartet dass sie dann zumindest
auch beschreiben wie sie diesen
militärischen Erfolg anstreben aber auch
hier war wohl nix sie folgen dem Rest
ihres Antrags nämlich schwammig zu
formulieren nichts präzise zu definieren
und vorab leider auch nicht genügend zu
recherchieren denn am Ende ihres Antrag
stellen Sie zwei Forderungen auf mit
denen viele Deutsche Bundestag jetzt an
die Regierung wenden soll
davon sind die meisten entweder durch
Vergangenes oder andauerndes
regierungshandel bereits erledigt liegen
in der Zuständigkeit der EU oder der UNO
und eben nicht bei uns oder sind
schlicht und der gleichen plattitüten
beispiele gefällig gerne Forderung 1 bis
4 die seilstrategie ist wie von Frau
Spellerberg erwähnt längst in Arbeit und
auch die Gespräche mit der Regierung in
niederzunehmen
auf Hochtouren
bei Forderung 3 da haben sie anscheinend
vergessen warum wir überhaupt im übrigen
mit Ihrer Zustimmung gemeinsam
entschieden haben eu-tm auslaufen zu
lassen und ebenso gut wie beendet haben
Forderungen 11 und 12 die liegen dagegen
ganz und gar in der Verantwortung der
Vereinten Nationen nämlich minusma
tatsächlich so auszugestalten wie es die
UN auch erwarten würden umso wichtig und
da bin ich der Verteidigungsministerin
auch der Außenministerin sehr dankbar
dass sie in den Gremien der UNO und bei
den Gesprächen auf internationale Ebene
auch den Finger in die Wunde legen und
definieren wo wir den Nachholbedarf
sehen
Probleme bei der Rotation fehlende
überfluggenehmungen aufgrund der
fehlenden Luftunterstützung geringere ja
manchmal auch kaum mehr vorhandene
Operationsfähigkeit das ist für unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten nicht nur
ärgerlich sondern im schlimmsten Fall
sogar ein Risiko und darum bin ich der
Bundesministerin aber auch der
werbeauftragten sehr dankbar dass sie
klar artikuliert haben dass wir dort
schnelle Lösungen erwarten ich darf an
der Stelle allen Soldatinnen und
Soldaten danken die in Mali im Einsatz
sind oder waren ich versichere Ihnen
dass für unsere Verantwortung für ihren
Einsatz wissen
welche Lösungen gibt es aber nun
sicherlich nicht die platteste aller
Antworten die von Herrn wundrak
formuliert nämlich sofort abzuziehen und
wir wissen alle dass es keine
schwarz-weiß oder ja Nein antworten gibt
und ja Herr Kollege schwarz für Lösungen
und für Entscheidungen braucht man
Grundlagen und ich glaube kramba diabi
hat es bereits erwähnt den sehr guten
Vorschlag den Gabriela eigentlich auch
aufgegriffen hat tatsächlich ist eine
robuste Mission der AU der Afrikanischen
Union überzuführen
dafür braucht es aber auch eine
übergangsperspektive und ein aktives
Engagement Deutschlands in der Region
wir werden als SPD-Fraktion daher
gemeinsam mit der Regierung an echten
Lösungen arbeiten die in Mali und das
salzzone eben nicht so leicht zu
erreichen sind nach der Kritik aber
gerne auch das Angebot ich freue mich
wenn die Parteien aus der Mitte des
Hauses gemeinsam Deutschlands
internationale Verantwortung und der
Verantwortung für die sehr heilregion
und Verantwortung für unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten gerecht werden wollen ich
freue mich daher auf die weiteren
Diskussionen im Ausschuss vielleicht
kommt noch was konstruktiveres danke für
die Aufmerksamkeit
und damit kommen wir auch zum letzten
Redner bevor diese Anträge in die
entsprechenden Ausschüsse überwiesen
werden das ist Thomas Silberhorn
erstsprecher für transatlantische
Beziehungen der Unionsfraktion die
natürlich auch bei diesen
internationalen Einsätzen von Bedeutung
sind
ich verstehe nicht ganz Herr Kollege
Schmidt weshalb sie so eine belehrenden
Ton in diese Debatte bringen diesen
Einsatz in Mali tragen viele Fraktionen
dieses Bundestages seit fast 10 Jahren
gemeinsam und im letzten Antrag auch
Mandatsverlängerung haben auch wir im
Mai diesen Jahres zugestimmt aber zum 31
Mai nächsten Jahres lauft laufen diese
Mandate aus und deswegen ist jetzt der
richtige Zeitpunkt eine kritische
Bestandsaufnahme einzufordern und zu
fragen wie denn unsere Zusammenarbeit in
den Sache Staaten künftig aussehen soll
und ob ein weiteres militärisches
Engagement in Mali überhaupt Sinn macht
lassen Sie mich vorab sagen die Seite
Region erfordert weiter unsere
uneingeschränkte Aufmerksamkeit in
Europa und es ist klar dass unsere
Unterstützung notwendig bleibt aber
insbesondere die Lage in Mali muss uns
zunehmend Sorge bereiten es war nicht
möglich nach dem Abzug der französischen
Kräfte der Mission Vulkane unsere
ausbildungsmission der Europäischen
Union in Mali vorzusetzen auch die
Vereinten Nationen können ihren
stabilisierungsauftrag nur eingeschränkt
wahrnehmen das militärischeem hat sich
ausgerechnet die russische Söldnergruppe
Wagner ins Land geholt die derzeit damit
beschäftigt ist in Russland
Strafgefangene und übrigens auch
ausländische Söldner zu rekrutieren für
den Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine und
deswegen meine Damen und Herren ist es
auch nicht verwunderlich dass die
Terrorismusbekämpfung in Mali durch
diese Kräfte keine Fortschritte erzielt
nur Herr Kollege lambsdorf es geht da
nicht um ein paar Söldner der russischen
wagnergruppe sondern es geht um die
Haltung der malischen Regierung die
malische Regierung hat nämlich
gleichzeitig den Einsatz der Bundeswehr
und anderer vn-truppen immer wieder
massiv behindert wenn die rettungsketten
nicht eingehalten werden können wenn die
Versorgung
gesenkt wird wenn lange geplante
personalrationen immer wieder verzögert
werden dann müssen wir doch hier mit
aller Deutlichkeit feststellen hier
werden rote Linien systematisch und
immer wieder überschritten und deswegen
stellt das dieses Verhalten der
malischen Regierung unser Engagement in
Frage und meine Damen und Herren es ist
genau deshalb jetzt der richtige
Zeitpunkt die Vorbereitungen zu treffen
für eine geordnete Beendigung des
Einsatzes dazu muss man ja in der Lage
sein wenn man das will und wenn es eine
nachfolgemission der Afrikanischen Union
gibt dann würde ich das sehr begrüßen
das wäre ein starkes Signal für die
Afrikanische Union zur Stabilisierung
auf dem eigenen Kontinent beizutragen
und es würde neue andere Möglichkeiten
der Unterstützung für uns eröffnen aber
selbst dann würde eine Fortsetzung der
militärischen Unterstützung für malen
nur dann Sinn machen wenn die malische
Regierung mit den international Truppen
kooperiert anstatt ihre bem zu
konterkarieren kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss Herr Kollege ich will meine
Damen und Herren nur sagen dass unsere
Angebote für Mali wie für Niger
vergleichbar sind in Liga ist die
Ausbildung sehr Kollege bitte ein
letzter Satz deswegen können wir eben
mit unserer Unterstützung nur verstärken
was vor Ort gelingt aber wir können die
eigene Anstrengung nicht ersetzen diese
eigene Anstrengung
ich schließe die Debatte Inter und da
wurde dem letzten reden dann doch zum
Schluss des Mikrofon abgestellt dass
passiert manchmal wenn sich die
Abgeordneten eben nicht an die Redezeit
halten und die entsprechenden
Anträge werden nun an die Ausschüsse
überwiesen ein von der CDU und einen von
der AFD